Let's look at the same example, starting off with this one.
But this one I'll actually be doing comparisons on ISO versus
aperture and shutters.
Filled out the same thing as before.
We're basically now going from increasing the speed from one-tenth to 2500.
So we basically increase the shutter speed.
Now, let's actually look at different ISO values.
One one hundred, 200 is the ISO.
This was 400, 800, 1600, 3200, 6400.
Now again you notice that as I got to 6400, it got much more brighter.
And this one is underexposed at 100.
So here somewhere in this range would have been a good choice of a ISO value,
with respect to what we want.
Of course, we could fill this out also.
So this is, ISO is increasing and this is shutter speed.
So you see the effect, and again, photographers do the best they can to
figure out what first scene that they want a different effect.
That's why they also carry a light meter sometimes, to kind of get a sense what
would be the best combination of the shutter speed, the aperture value and
ISO they could use for the for the purpose of the pictures they are taking.